[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ses paroles oui c'est habillée en vous
et le pentax sais pas si c'est vrai il
ya même eu un pantalon et ouais
j'adore ça shaiba ça va je rappelle
qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui m'écrivent
sur les réseaux combats se déroulent et
la bar mitzvah tu saches elle bat à ce
sera donc le 12 septembre inquiétez pas
content on ouvrira bien entendu pas mal
j'ai mis pour vous et pour le public les
batteries mais profondes y avait deux
groupes
le mec se la pète à peine arrivé il a
fait trois chroniques jeunesse pour vous
le public sort et crois que le public se
dit comment vas tu as signé sept albums
et chaque semaine billie jean wallon
mais bref je te le dis chaque semaine
vous me charrier sur le costume donc je
me suis dit là je viens mettre un
costume sobre
alors on va expliquer à stéphane et aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils connaissent pas
les missions ce qui avait plus en plus
de gens qui regardent les pmp moi il ya
des gens ils pensent que je suis arrivé
hier
ça fait dix ans que je suis là bas oui
j'arrive et je n'avais pas végéter
kodiak jamais sa gueule j'allais sa
gueule regardez le avant après pour voir
ce que j'ai mangé illégal
oui j'en ai pris dans la tronche et ah
bon alors oui et en fait il regarde tout
ce qui se passe pendant les pubs en
coulisse ma vie que je parlais que vous
parlez pas de vous parler et je ne parle
pas bien compris oui voilà très bien
c'est que ça va partir en sucette
toujours de se resserrer à oui il ya de
l'énorme dossier mais on commence comme
chaque semaine est sûre il t'a c'est le
moment où je me transforme
celui que sur tf1 c'est mon pote c'est
nikos cellule où on connaissait cyril
animateurs on connaissait cyril
producteurs voici tout de suite
cyril maintenant ça se transmet de père
en fils de p
et on commence tout avec baba savez vous
que les sous secret c'est incroyable à
bonbons sucrés c'est que j'ai je sais
pas je n'ai pas de secret moi je peux du
cul
je vous interdis un jour au tpp sachez
le il n'y a que des sales gosses ou
thomas table s'affaissera sont quatorze
ans que le prince philip et o'connell à
rennes je sais j'ai un truc de fou ou
alors aller avec le décès du prince il y
beaucoup ont découvert un homme cache
marron borderline limite ils sont en
pointe alors je vous donnais des
citations
vous connaissiez tiffany bonvoisin aussi
tu fanny canteloup le look avec les
principes d'un extrait d'une histoire
d'amour traité fusionnelle
c'est qu'ils sont des crayonnés
visiblement isabella des infos sur les
chirurgies de benjamin castaldi et avec
ils l'ont fait un nouveau prêt plus à
l'école quoi
valérie ne se sent pas bien grosse
menteur baba du bled et là ça va la
série tu es sûr que tu veux tu peux pas
une prélature de l'acod la maîtrise car
il fait chaud peut-être anna ouvrait un
peu une porte
à peine arrivé stevie a envie de se
faire toucher les bouley jessy matador
mais après ce matin calme ici on a des
bd des blessures du passé moi je suis
pas médecin je pas g
[Musique]
et quand benjamin castadi radio tu l'as
vue il est pas content le camarade après
le barrio anglais le barrio brésilien
baba est touché tout nouveau variant est
je crois que j'ai le variant algérien
moi j'ai toujours envie de danser du
rail le mistral ne pas que dans plus
belle la vie illégalement dans la gueule
d'isabelle morini-bosc toujours
et attention scoop de guillaume genton
c'est un super ouais franchement tu as
volé à voler a volé la carte soraya pas
de voleurs
c'est ainsi
la carte sans rien regarder non rien
soit regardé ça mais je ne sais si la
tradition on finit avec le conseil de la
semaine cinéma
ne pensez pas à losail penser à qui fait
c'est ça votre problème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
et
j'ai demandé à stéphane g 20 ne voulait
toujours rester fiers d'être bien
décontracté ces petits bouts
cette nature voilà c'est que lui il est
parfait dans le casting de rêve vous
êtes contents et castaldi très content
la notion d'accueil bien stéphane 13 ans
qui est super gentil va pas taper à
l'échoppé où ces variants algérien quoi
j'ai tout le temps envie de danser durée
de ce moment c'est vrai que c'est un
garde à vue pourrait stock-option du
right to do conde en syrie
cette bête de scène que j'ai à côté de
moi pourquoi on a retrouvé cette
personne c'est grâce au public de fous
[Applaudissements]
à
alors merci les séries
il y aura du public aussi qui viendra
devoir j'espère bientôt on pourra ouvrir
l'instant sont que ce sont des
intermittents qui sont payés qui sont
très contents d'être là pour la plupart
[Applaudissements]
faut savoir qu'on a une particularité
dans cette émission je le retirerai
c'est la première fois que le public
gagnent plus que les chroniques ce
public c'est le même si c'est des
intermittents ils mettent une ambiance
de ouvre sur un bateau et du coup ça a
réveillé la limmat servi la bête qui
sommeille en vous parce que c'est vrai
que en menaçant public c'est comme un
couscous une boulette
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est cool
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
deschacht qui fait sa crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
[Musique]
bon sang l'anniversaire ton patron ton
boss pas faire une danse musique
[Applaudissements]
ben
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour ce soufflé les chiens est-ce
important pour ceux qui nous regardent
leur faites pas ça chez vous c'est fait
par les professionnels par contre si
andré sauf que c'est moi je suis jaloux
vous faites une danse pour alexandre
guerrier mais par contre parmi ce public
stéphane est pas dans ce soit
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tu avais posé la question je
suis toujours super content on dit
[Rires]
souvent mon entourage à mes amis les
plus proches
cyril est un garde son cap corse et pour
la danse et cédez pas je te le dis
j'aurais droit que je ne fais d'habitude
compétition j'étais rarement comme ça
vraiment je vais pas témoin ah c'est
vrai que vous êtes défoncer au jus
lamine sy savané attention je suis
habité mois cyril stade du ray
m'intéressait avoué benjamin castaldi à
l'ats pascal boudeuse ses 40 ans de
carrière avoue deux séries les benjamins
c'est également en 400 millions dans les
poches enfin plus de ce côté c'est
également tu dégages car à penhars plus
de cet été bc quatre ans d'âge mental et
ça c'est des deux côtés par des rythmes
efficaces que gp non j'ai fait conscient
de délos évoque du coup les deux ont 4
ans d'âge mental pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de se bagarrer avec
pendant les pubs alors ça vous ne le
voyez pas et donc je vais ramener toutes
les images
alors qui maquille c'est la question
qu'on se pose quand même et une belle
brise c'est moi je me pose pas la
question
et bien la réponse c'est mon ami
après des années de rixes de menaces de
pugilat panique ils se retrouvent sur un
plateau télé je vais fort sa gueule toi
tu vas alors toi toi tu vas me défonce à
moi en direct en direct qu'est-ce que ça
castagne était prêt à vous la jeune
fille enfin pas encore c'est donc
combattant courageux prêts là d'accord
on est prêt je suis prêt la franchise à
gbadolite encore pris au pied du mur
cast a été obligé de s'entraîner mais
même là c'était une des mères sûr de sa
force de son côté pas parce exercer
tranquillement
tel un ninja tunisien tellement sûr de
sa force baba se permet même de donner
des conseils à casta ça prend un coup
les attaques mois la jeune fille qu'elle
tibia
faire tout à gré sa blessure trop
d'honneur est en jeu c'est la sueur des
places et montent au lait le combat
avait enfin lieu j'arrête un massacre
[Musique]
plus proche de la danse que du combat et
comment allait finir cette altercation
tout simplement avec une fleur j en
panne du sport
tu es gosnay c'est bien dit embêté de sa
victoire cyril sans l'excusé la plus
pourrie de l'histoire des excuses parce
que tu es beau tu es n'a fait mal et
beau gosse c'était beau c'était bon
tiers
bakaba mission espagnole est toujours
assez drôle et bien ses défauts est allé
boosheri signer la semaine derni cette
semaine a eu à sauver cette personne je
sais pas si vous en souvenez origin
s'est cassé car c'est carla car
l'organisateur de soirées clandestines
alors eux ils voulaient témoigner à
bientôt chez nous well as tu relâches
anonyme il connaissait pas la prod ils
connaissaient pas la chaîne du coup moi
j'ai recueilli d'autres témoignages
anonymes
vous allez voir que on a des exclus ils
ont participé de près ou de loin dans
des soirées clandestines
aujourd'hui anonymement il témoigne moi
je balance jamais je suis professionnel
je donne jamais non en plus si je
dénonce benjamin castaldi ça va mettre
un terme à sa carrière télévisuelle
enfin ce qu'il en reste combien vous
avez payé votre feuille alors autour de
gpu below de son repos les rebelles lui
c'est le plus de ce temps votre septième
étage et auquel elle assistait voulait
dire la france à
vous êtes très piquant et ben ça tombe
bien puisque avant de partir on relance
une séquence que les téléspectateurs
vont beaucoup réclamaient c'est le jeu
qui va partir en sucette sur la tête de
tata jeu diffusé un court extrait et ça
crée des problèmes
la semaine dernière nicolas pernikoff et
gilles verdez ont réglé leur différend
cette semaine c'est un souci entre vous
guillaume genton et benjamin castaldi
pour les mêmes étrille on regarde et on
en parle juste après toujours les mêmes
le jeu de ça va partir en sucette sur la
tête des cotes
[Musique]
je m'attends sur twitter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde ce qu'il a trouvé guillaume
genton gasquet dans voici
c'est incroyable ce héros des bâtards de
ça va partir en sucette sur la tête des
top
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est celle que vous ne pouvez
pas nous laisser nous alors possible le
même jour c'était beau concept menteur
qui m'ont élu nantais en allemand arrêté
var était parfaite
je vais diffuser des douze jours ils
arrêtent alors ils moi ça me fait rire
de la preuve j'ai amené ce qui se passe
ce téléphone pourquoi cirer les bancs
[Musique]
est-ce que j'étais au cours de la
séquence dit la vérité alors pas du tout
cyril n'est pas au courant de ce que je
viens d'énoncer s'il n'ya plus d'intérêt
bas et donc là j'ai ramené la preuve
c'est que je suis là dit que je vous
annonce tout est ce que benjamin
castaldi on peut diffuser faussement
d'amnésie c'est faible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est le truc le plus gros canada
méritait pas ça ils ont été très bons en
trombe et j'aurais aimé le trouver
marion va fermer
séverine leduc et à la région ce n'est
pas la route et passera pas l'air simple
1 voilà
[Rires]
ses toiles présentées
[Applaudissements]
il